ladies and gentlemen it has been a very
very good week it's been a very good
past couple of months I hope you're all
very happy as Bud Light collapses Modelo
becomes number one Target stock is
crumbling and all of those who Embrace
wokeness in these big corporations are
seeing the stock take a big hit we now
have CNN CEO Chris Licht out after Trump
Town Hall he's gone they can't even host
the front runner for the GOP the
corporate press is dead Tucker Carlson
gets 80 million views on Twitter Nothing
is Stopping the uh the cultural shift
the victories or or the strengthening
the what what we're doing have any
popular and I really I use that word
lightly have any of the popular hosts
from CNN tried to launch any kind of web
show no but they would they would take
off if they did if Don Lemon started his
own web show he'd be like making 10
million dollars or completely wrong I
thought you're being sarcastic you
actually think that Donald Chris Cuomo
if he started his own Chris Cuomo is on
what news Nations hitting 40 000 hits
yeah nothing yeah it because this is the
reality maybe it's too late like you
know personalities they are fake
personalities no one actually watches
Tucker is an actual thought leader with
tons of fans and followers that's right
I did Don Lemon show Once in 2000
11 or 12 maybe I'm sorry like 13 or 14.
it was on uh BLM riots and we got into
somewhat of an intellectual debate about
uh I my point was you know he said well
let's bring let's bring it down he said
you know I said well look BLM is a
disjointed organization as the
leadership that's why you've got some
Maniacs going out there burning
buildings down he says well who would be
a leader I said well I don't know Oprah
this woman is a businesswoman she knows
and I got into how this woman created a
two billion dollar Empire from and lemon
was like a deer in the headlights he's
just a dim bulb he's a dumb guy he's not
an intelligent guy he could never to
Tim's point he could never pull off when
Tucker pulled off Anderson Cooper he'd
be he'd be making some good money I
think I don't think so I think he'd make
more than done than the other people
yeah probably but nowhere near Tucker
territory right no not and it depends on
her to find a good I mean I I guess I
couldn't even really put an estimate on
it yeah I I look look Anderson Cooper is
a famous guy he can make money Don Lemon
is laughably bad however
how many people have you ever met where
they're like yo did you cut did you
catch Cooper 360 last night right right
yeah did you hear what he had to say
well every Tucker Carlson has fans and
followers Anderson Cooper does does not
he has a little bit a little bit he is a
celebrity but most people just know who
he is because of the ads and the
Billboards whereas the people who know
Tucker know him for his thoughts and his
monologues his ideas exactly his
dedicated followers too you know Cooper
and lemon and Chris Cuomo as well they
were background fodder right people
watch airport news yeah they watched CNN
they were on in the background they knew
them they were comfortable the only
place I could see an Anderson Cooper
ending up he'd be he'd be like one of
those Discovery ID investigative guys or
like not Geo reports said give him a
show they give him a few million bucks a
year yeah he'd get a good send-off from
the CIA for all of his years of hard
work that's a joke calm down maybe and
he and Kendall and
so
Tucker Carlson when he was let go from
Fox we spent so much time speculating
over what story he broke that was the
straw that broke the camel's back
because Tucker was subversive and he
actually reported on things that people
in power didn't want the American people
to know about that's how you know he was
a good reporter that's how you know he
was genuinely good at his job rather
than just being popular because we were
having conversations about the stories
he broke the things he talked about that
no one else was willing to touch and we
couldn't even narrow down which one it
was that got him fired because there was
so much when Don Lemon got pushed out of
CNN no one was wondering oh yeah which
story do you think which subversive
story that Don Lemon broke wow do you
think was the reason those powerful
people pushed him out we were actually
arguing what unstable Outburst led to
his that's true is that why he got yes
Vivek Ramen when he snapped on Vivek
reportedly whatever ethnicity he is yeah
that's what he said oh yeah and he said
whatever ethnicity you are what wow he's
not the brightest bulb in the box but
I'll I'll actually disagree I'll agree
with you and disagree with you on Tucker
p people forget the intangible attacker
guy's been around DC a long time he
belongs to All the Right private clubs
he knows where a lot of bodies are
buried a lot I think it's as much about
the stories he hasn't yet done that's a
very as much as the stories he did and
the stories they didn't want done dude
that's a really good one I didn't even
consider that and and they know he's
shown them over the past several years
like yeah he's telling those kinds of
stories man he's like got Epstein's
Client List and he's just like that's
what I'm she's like I've been waiting
for a slow news day he's like he's got
people are only talking about the
Wildfire he's got a lot I mean you made
a statement earlier when you were
preempting your your ideas that uh when
when Fox let Tucker go but I think
technically they didn't let him go they
have him on a golden handcuff on
contract they do so I love Tucker and
what he's done and what he represents
but I also look at this as cut and dry
Fox owns him they're gonna sue him get a
ton of money for breach of contract and
he's gonna have to stop making content
I'm gonna disagree with you I think I
think he's got the kind of dollar
dollars liquid that he just gonna turn
around and say hell with you guys and
he's going to throw a ton of money at
attorneys he's going to fight him he's
going to jam them up one thing Fox
doesn't want to do it's not unique to
Fox it's every large corporation they
don't want to peel back onions in
Discovery that's the last thing they
want to do because look you gotta
remember when you when you produce
discovery of things pertinent to a
lawsuit you you're pretty much
self-policed right you produce what you
and your attorneys feel is pertinent to
Discovery your attorney is officer of
the court is trusted that you're
producing what you're supposed to
produce well Tucker knows a lot more
about the interim imaginations of fox
than Dominion does the last thing fox
wants is for Tucker in Discovery the
compelled discovery on some things that
should have been produced to Dominion
but weren't and have dominion reopen
another matter wow so you think that
Tucker will threaten to take it to court
and then they'll drop the case I think
they'll ignore them he'll ignore them
he'll just hire attorneys I don't think
he'll even hire an attorney well I think
he has to right because if they sue him
well they're going to have
I imagine what they'll do is they'll
send the lawsuit with intent with a
letter of intent to file claims or
whatever to engage yeah those kind of
sample complain like a mock complaint
then that's right not yet filed and
here's what we're gonna do if you don't
stop and then he hires a lawyer or he
might even still just ignore it and say
file it in court because he just
represents himself no no because they're
not gonna because the moment they do he
can say okay I agree Discovery time baby
because it's not his his computer is
being opened up it's theirs oh it's
theirs look they're gonna they're gonna
ask him for Discovery but his is real
Limited in scope right if they're going
to be ambiguous about why they let him
go or they severed ties or they benched
him he can turn around and play dumb say
I have no idea let's open everything yep
that's the last thing they want to do do
you think they want I mean you know the
head of PR at Fox has a reputation for
being a notoriously Evil Woman
yeah I don't know what's their name
because I mean she's in PR right there's
a reason you get good at convincing
people that someone with a bad
reputation has a good one
they want are her texts and emails to be
produced in Discovery especially the
internal stuff so it would be pretty
brutal I think I think he's got them
he's got them in a rough spot so would
they release him from his contract then
or they just let it I mean it depends on
how the attorneys look listen he's going
to claim they owe him money they're
gonna claim he owes them money and at
the end of the day yeah or they might
just watch it out he'll say just leave
me alone and let me go and they'll say
we're not going to give you a dime and
everybody away maybe I think it's more
likely that he wins something he
probably will yeah because because
everybody else has lost this golden
handcuffs thing is is going to be viewed
very negatively in my opinion if it does
ever go to court and they know that that
Tucker was contracted to produce a show
to host a show they then decided he will
not do that so now they either let him
go or they pay up and so he's saying if
you if the if if we have an agreement
where it's like I'll pay you X in
exchange for you to come on the show and
then I tell you you can never come on
again and then you say well then I'm
going to leave I said no you can't do
that either like I can't do that like
that's ridiculous the agreement is that
you are hosting the show now they may
have something in these contracts
because they're robust contracts but I
really doubt that there's going to be a
judge who's like well no Tucker you're
not allowed to work right now it's more
likely going to be like this makes no
sense there should be a settlement for
for separation right right in which case
Tucker will likely say you've got to pay
me X so
I've been I've been in these media
contracts before and people have asked
me like oh what if you know you leave or
like what if they they don't want you
around I'm like they got to Pat the
remainder of the contract that's the
purpose of the contract it guarantees I
get X dollars for this time period if at
any point they want to break that
they're gonna pay me out
I I assume what they're trying to do is
say we didn't actually fire Tucker they
did and Tucker would argue they fired me
in breach of the contract so they have
to pay me out and I'm leaving as opposed
to if he chose to leave then they would
just wouldn't pay him out and then they
may actually say you're on the hook for
yeah they want to claw back right some
some of the uh income we paid you for
three years right and if you leave they
might say he owes us the remainder of
those years you know one of the things
that leads me to believe
I agree with him and think that fox the
last thing they want is just to go to
litigation is they're not slamming them
in the Press they haven't they haven't
leaked anything on them they haven't
dropped nasty releases on them they're
being really tepid in the way they
approach them they're tiptoeing around
him part of that's obviously they don't
want to lose the remaining viewers is
that they've kept but uh it's an unusual
way to go about it when you're going you
know he's a Grizzly right you typically
take a kill shot when you go bear
hunting like that yes and not doing that
if he had violated the contract that
would have been the first sentence out
of them out of their mouths yeah yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time